Our cells have two copies of all our genetic
information meaning we have two copies of
each gene in every cell of our body. Cancer can
develop when cells acquire mutations over time.
Both copies of a gene need to be
mutated for cancer to develop.
Gene mutations can be either inherited
or acquired. Inherited mutations are
called germline mutations and acquired
mutations are called somatic mutations.
Somatic mutations or acquired mutations happen
when genes mutate over a person's lifetime and
are present in the tumor. They are not inherited
or passed down to children. Somatic mutations may
be caused by environmental factors, habits, diet,
or by chance. Most cancers are caused by somatic
mutations. Currently we cannot determine the exact
cause of somatic mutations in individual patients.
Inherited mutations or germline mutations are
typically passed down from one of your parents.
Approximately five to ten percent of
cancers are due to inherited gene mutations.